my name is Jacob Kabbalah I teach
history and digital studies at Davidson
College and today I'll be speaking about
using computational methods of
hierarchical clustering and machine
learning to predict and identify unknown
authors in corpora of medieval Latin
texts
so I will talk today about a an
application of computational methods to
a problem in the humanities and the
problem the humanities is a very old one
it's about authorship attribution and I
am this back when I'm a medievalist by
training and so I'll be talking about
text written in Latin the problem is
that we have lots and lots of texts that
come to the Middle Ages
in a variety of languages a Latin Greek
Old English whole Church Slavonic and
for thousands of these texts we simply
don't know who wrote them and the
question then is can computational
methods help us determine who wrote
texts the case study see that make it's
bigger the case study I wanted I'll talk
to you today about is that of the
so-called galas anonymous and the monk
of lado the monk of lado is the name
that we have given to a text composed in
the early 12th century called the
translation of st. Nicholas to Venice
it's about 12,000 words long I was
written most likely between 1102 1108 in
Venice the second text Gallus anonymous
who wrote the first chronicle of the
Polish history the deeds of the princess
of the poles the texts about twice as
long written about five to ten years
later in Poland and I've given you a map
here just to give you an orientation of
place yellow dots correspond to the life
as we know it of Calais red dots
correspond to the life as we know it of
its a monk and the question is and I can
get into this later if you're interested
are these two anonymous authors or one
of the same author and there have been
there's been a long debate in the field
of history that saying yes they are no
they're not well so what is the case I
have been working on an authorship
attribution a package to work on
problems such as this and so I've called
it authorship
okay great thanks so we need to put
together some corpora of texts that are
similar within which we can compare the
two so luckily for us medievalist we
have lots and lots of texts from the
Middle Ages available in digital form so
it's a matter of downloading those and I
want to show you the details of how I
import them and so on but the I'll just
show you the their makeup here we have a
make this smaller
the first corpus and I'm testing the
similarity between these two texts so
I'm testing of similarity all right well
there's a similarity between them that
the first in four different corpora the
first corpus contains 39 texts and
here's a mixture of different genres so
we have theological works we have
historical works we have letters all
different kinds of genre and all
different kinds of word lengths so the
longest text in this corpus here is over
150,000 words the shortest one is about
10,000 words or so second text can is is
a second corpus contains all of these 39
texts but broken up into roughly equal
length segments an idea there is to see
does there you see the so here we have
the text and the corpus with with its
length and words idea there is the test
does the length of a text to make a
difference in accuracy of attribution
third corpus here I've it's a taken the
this this corporate what I'm calling
corpus for and I apologize for the for
the
numbering system but it's the way I've
been doing the research and it's just
too complicated for me to change it
corpus 3 contains it's a subset of
corpus form where I have controlled for
genre so it's a smaller corpus about 69
texts total here we have roughly same
lengths same genre but I call this
unbalanced one because some of the
authors for example Liam of mom is a
Barry has many representative texts in
here whereas others have just a couple
representative texts and this law for
that problem that's a problem that comes
up in machine learning applications and
I'll talk about that in a second this is
a corpus six a subset of the final one
in which I have balanced out the author
classes so here every author has about
two to three texts representative texts
about 12,000 words long let's see if
this works any better okay so there you
see the the four different corpora that
I'm interested in and these are all
taken from 11th and 12th century Latin
prose next step then is to extract
features and is to translate all of
these texts into some kind of numerical
form which we can then compare
mathematically for this experiment I've
just taken most frequent words so here
and this is a function that I've
included in this package I'm building I
calculates say the 250 most frequent
words in eaten an entire corpus so if
you do that for the in the third corpus
just to give you a sense you get a list
250 words these are also called function
words the ands the in deeds their fors
and whatnot those words that we use most
frequently but we use without really
thinking about them and there they turn
out to be the some of the best
indicators of of authorship next up then
is for every text in a corpus to
calculate the frequencies of occurrence
of those 250 most frequent words in each
member text and what that produces then
is
something like this where here we have a
every text you see on the left here
corresponds to a long list of
frequencies and these are the giving of
the words at these are the frequencies
of this particular word in this
particular text the next step in final
step is to prepare for cross validation
and this is because it turns out that
you can check your work and also even
improve accuracy if you repeat the same
process not for entire text segments but
if you first sample out a random number
of words from each text segment and then
calculate the frequencies of the most
frequent words in those random so called
bags of words and here I've done that
four bags of words taken from each text
with five thousand long so five thousand
word bags taken from each text then when
we calculate the frequencies of those
most frequent words we get something
similar and here so for every corpus we
have 10 different samplings and this is
some doing this in order to validate the
results we get later on and again each
one of these 250 frequencies long okay
then there turn out there are two broad
approaches to dealing with this so now
we have lots of data in numerical form
and we can do something with it two
broad approaches our distance measures
and machine learning approaches distance
methods first we can import the
hierarchical clustering package that
comes with Mathematica and then
visualize the distances between our
texts and in a dendrogram the way these
work so here for example I'm this is
just a little helper function I wrote
but we're looking at distances in corpus
six as determined by whichever one of
these distance measures we select
Euclidean distance squared Euclidean
trust
bored Manhattan and so on are we done to
break her his distance and these are
eight distance measures for numerical
data that come with Mathematica and so
we can see you can see two things on
this dendrogram one is that the closer
to the right of the plot two texts are
connected that means the closer they are
in the lower the distance the smaller
distance between them you can also see
that based on how different texts how
close they are on this y-axis and indeed
if you take a look you see that texts
written by the same author and the
author name you see as the first element
of the label there do tend to cluster
together so these three segments written
by Luke brand cluster these three
segments written by militaire a cluster
etc the two halves of Gallus and the one
half and and the in a segment of the
Monk also cluster together here and in
fact some of the distance measures
cluster or indicate that the distance
between the monks text and the first
half of galaxy's text is smaller than
the distance between the two halves of
Gallus so that's interesting if you do
that though for a big corpora it becomes
difficult to so this is the fourth
corpus we have a hundred and sixteen
text segments you see the same pattern
authors cluster together but it's
difficult to interpret this so is there
a way of measuring accuracy then and for
accuracy with this method I simply mean
how effective are the eight distance
measures at placing a text in a corpus
as closest to another text written by
the same author that we definitely know
was written by the same author when we
do this we get neat results so this is
just a tabulation
of these results for you in corpus 0
which is again varying lengths and
varying genres we get the highest
accuracy rate of about 77% so out of
seven possible accurate attributions
there 21 this goes up in the other
corpora to about 98% in corpus three
same 98% best performing one corpus for
and 100 percent accuracy for these
within this corpus of course in corpus
six a couple things to see here just all
together the chess board distance is
uniformly it appears ill-suited to
determining authorship the best
performing distance across the board
here seems to be the break curtis
distance and manhattan distance which
are mathematically related
cross-validation running the same doing
the same process on each of those bags
of words taken within every corpus
confirms these results and it doesn't
seem to be a fluke so if if especially
within corpus for notice also the
difference between 0 and 4 0 & 4 contain
the same words they just corpus 0
contains these texts that are some are
150,000 words long some are 10,000 words
long corpus 4 contains those same text
but split up into segments notice what
happens to the accuracy there it shoots
up to the about ninety seven point four
point five percent their meaning genre
of a written work is not a hindrance to
determining or it's a tributing
authorship within the corpora the length
of the text is so that's an interesting
to me result so this works pretty well
how would do Galison and monk do here
well within corpus 0 the least well
performing corpus the text closest to
monk
according to seven out of the eight
measures is indeed Gallus the one
outlier is the poorly performing
transport distance
and in the reverse the text closest to
Galus is amongst text again with a
couple exceptions here this is confirmed
also in in the other corpora so we
always have we have a pretty pretty
clear signal here at least within the
corpora that these two texts are really
close to each other the subsampling also
confirms this to be the case so out of
ten subsamples in corpus zero the
best-performing distances without fail
attribute Galus the monk and so on
here we see also 10 of 10 out of 10 10
out of 10 10 out of 10 I will let's see
I will skip this now and move to the
machine learning as an approach so this
is that's one approach distances the
other approach is machine learning and I
learned quite a lot today earlier in the
afternoon about the deeper possibilities
of machine of of mathematical machine
learning so this may seem a little
rudimentary but it's so incredibly
effective the basic idea here is we
treat authors as classes and we treat
the frequency lists as items that we can
assign to a class and thereby using the
classify function to train a classifier
the one method involved here is known as
leave one out cross validation which
I'll just play these out so it's the the
process takes out say the very first one
of these frequency lists builds a
classifier with the remaining frequency
lists in which this frequency list will
be attributed assign the class cosmas
this one to class cosmas this one's a
classic Albert etc I'll be done a line
then it takes out the second one and
builds a class of and trains a and built
a tree it classifies a machine using the
training set consisting of all the
remaining ones etc all the way down the
line so here we have 69 excuse me 39
different texts so we'll get 39
different training sets the results of
this are also pretty good here we see
what happens to full texts so and here's
a corpus for what is the first closest
author class to which this text belongs
and the the method I've been using here
is logistic regression which proves to
be very robust for multi class problems
like such as this one where it's not
just is an author is not another but
there are many different types of
possible many different classes of
authors so if you looked down the line
here sure by-and-large authors text
could attribute it to the proper the
correct author class all the way down
the line with a few exceptions here our
monk gets attributed to class Gallus
with 80% or so certainty the results are
a bit more easily digestible if we look
at the cross validation results and so
here I wonder if I could make this
smaller yes so here for every one of
these bags of words repeated this method
and the the ss1 ss2 as a subsample one
subsample two and you see that tad of
ten times this particular text is
attributed to the core to the correct
after class then I have ten times and
you can see on the right this particular
tax was attributed author class and so
on the ones where we see absolutely no
correct attributions are by and large
the ones where we would expect no
correct attributions because if you
notice if we take out this text from the
corpus then there is no remaining text
belonging to the author class cosmas
with which in the training set so once
we pass in an unknown author there
simply is no possibility of correct
attribution the results get much better
again in the later corpora so and you
can see that here how so how exactly
effective is this method it turns out it
is just as effective on full text as the
distance method and it's so more
effective than the distance method when
you do bags of words so even within
corpus 0 the the wildest and corpus of
the four we get eighty-three percent
accuracy of attribution you using the
bags of word method finally how what is
it where does this what does what does
this give us as results for the the case
study that that I've proposed monk the
the monks text does seem to be
classified as Gallus for four out of
four times and without fail also during
in the subsampling conclusions it seems
that distance measures and machine
learning algorithms and in particular
that break hardest distance and logistic
regression proved remarkably good at
identifying Latin authors on the basis
of most frequent word frequencies I
mentioned the second conclusion earlier
which is that text length within a
corpus uniform text length is a much
much more important for accurate
attribution than a genre as long as you
have equal text lengths in the corpus
you'll get good results if you have
mixed genre that doesn't that doesn't
make a difference there seems little
doubt based on this too that galas and
Monk are one of the same again however
in the context the corpora that I've
assembled so the next steps out of many
but one of the major next steps would be
to broaden and in Lardon to make the
corpus much bigger see what kind of
results we get when we take say if it's
possible all texts all Latin texts that
survived from the early 12th century or
first half a twelfth century you can
also try different parameters so
different sizes of bags of words for
subsampling different numbers of the
most frequent words we can also try a
whole series of different features
altogether so instead of counting words
count character sequences character
engrams parts of speech syntactical
features and so on so thanks for
listening
[Applause]